توصل القوات الروسيه محاوله تطويق مدينه
بخموت والتقدم في اجزاء اخرى من منطقه
دنيتك ولهانسك ياتي هذا فيما يحاول الجنود
الاوكرانيون الصمود عبر اطلاق صواريخ على
مواقع العدو
يتقدم في كل دقيقه وفي كل ثانيه على كل
مناطق خط المواجهه بهذا صبرنا ودعمنا
المدفعي مهم للغايه للجميع
وفق الجيش الاوكراني فان جنوده صدّ ما زاد
عن 100 هجوم على مدى الساعات 24 الماضيه
في بخموت وهي مدينه يتركز عليه هجوم
القوات الروسيه منذ اغسطس اب الخميس شنت
روسيا كذلك قصفا مدمرا على مدن في انحاء
اوكرانيا هدفها تقليل قدره اوكرانيا على
القتال في مكان تؤكد ان الضربات الجويه
ليس لها اي اغراض عسكريه بل تهدف لايذاء
وتخويف المدنيين
دوله ارهابيه شنت هجوما ادى الى انقطاع
مؤقت للكهرباء والتدفئه والمياه في بعض
مناطقنا ومدننا واوده الصواريخ الروسيه
بحياته سته اوكرانيين
تعازيه للاسر
من جانبها كررت روسيا نفيها استهداف
المدنيين واوضحت انها شن الضربه انتقاميه
ضخمه ردا على مداهمه عبر الحدود الاسبوع
الماضي واشارت الى انها دمرت في هذه
الضربه قواعد لاطلاق الطائرات المسيره
وعطلت السكك الحديديه والحقت اضرارا
بمنشات تصنيع وتصليح الاسلحه لمدينه بخموت
اهميه استراتيجيه كبرى لموسكو اذ تعتبرها
بمثابه خطوه للتامين محيط منطقه جمباز وهي
هدف اساسي للحرب
ان المدينه التي اصبحت مدمره ليس لها قيمه
استراتيجيه كبيره